Good afternoon everybody.
Today, we're going to to do a session
on B2B product with a panel.
Jason Lemkin is going to moderate.
Thank you very much.
We have Solomon from Docker,
Tracy from Plangrid, and Harry from Lob.
Thank you all very much for coming.
>> So, this is a great session, everyone
seen all the prior sessions online, right?
Raise your hand if you haven't.
All right, good, 100%.
They're great.
So I watched Stewart Butterfield and
others.
And what I thought would be particularly
fun since we have three amazing founders
here of B2B companies, is to particularly
hone in on the intersection of building
great products and revenue because we
all want to be product visionaries.
I certainly did myself.
But if you can't sell it and
it's a B2B product, ultimately,
what's the point of all of it.
So I want to dig into a couple of stories
both in the early days and a little bit
later to help folks like you who probably
just have inklings on how to potentially
monetize your dreams because the stories
are always different than we think.
So let me give 10 seconds
on each of the panelists,
then let me have them dig in a little
bit more on their companies.
But Solomon from Docker, I don't know
who here knows about Docker, but
I'm guessing most of the 300,000
folks online that'll read it.
But Docker, he'll give you some
more context, founded in 2010,
but not as Docker,
what was it called back then?
>> dotCloud.
>> dotCloud, which we'll get to a story,
raised almost 200 million,
and Docker is sort of
a foundational piece of infrastructure
that everyone builds up around today.
So we'll get into that, but it is
seven years into this journey, right?
Into a likely 70 year journey or
14 year journey.
Tracy probably gets probably in
the middle of this rock star group.
Plangrid was found a little bit later.
2011?
>> 2011.
>> Got it.
Raised 60 million?
>> Something like that.
>> Right.
So money isn't everything, but
it does help.
And Plangrid you'll learn is super cool,
automates construction management and
kind of has shaken up
a shockingly large industry,
shockingly large parts of software and
you'll learn a little bit more about
those stories and I want to learn more.
And then Harry runs Lob which turns mail
into an API which I think
is pretty interesting.
Raised $10 million and so
he's got another $190 million to catch up.
$50 million, but
off to a very strong start.
Founded in 2013?
>> Yes.
>> What's that?
[INAUDIBLE] Yeah, all right, and
in you're four years in, right?
So it's just when it's getting both
good and hard, right, at the same time.
I would imagine, right?
So I want to begin but those are the
intros, but give me a little bit more
Intro on the company like number of
employees, and what's the latest challenge
you have today, or
any other quick tidbits on the company.
>> Sure.
So currently it's 350 employees at Docker.
We actually started in 2008.
>> 2008?
>> Yeah.
We're bootstrapped in France and
then it wasn't working, so
we moved here got into YC and
that really, really, really helped.
So anyway.
>> Got it.
>> Nine years.
>> [LAUGH]
>> You just sort of refound the company or
do you count those earlier so you-
>> It depends who you ask but yeah.
>> [LAUGH]
>> It counts, the same company,
same problem we're trying to solve.
So 350 employees, lot's of growth,
lot's of excitement.
The biggest challenge for us, the biggest
challenge last year was proving that we
could build a business, a viable hi-growth
business on top of this excitement for
stuff that is in large part free,
in open source.
That was last year,
we proved that model and
this year we have
the challenge is to scale it.
And to scale it faster than our
competitors who now figured out that
the model is proven.
So it's a big competitive battle and
a really lucrative space, so
that's the challenge this year.
>> Good.
>> [INAUDIBLE]
>> Hi, everyone, my name is Tracy Young.
I'm one of the cofounders and
CEO of Plangrid.
Plangrid builds, as you said, beautiful,
simple, effective software for
the construction industry.
We emerged from
Y Combinators Winners 2012 batch.
And since then, we've grown from
five co-founders to 310 people,
which is not something to brag about,
it means our payroll is very high.
>> [LAUGH]
>> But we've helped build over 500,000
construction projects from the smallest
kitchen remodels to the largest projects
in the world and
we are available on all the platforms.
Apple actually named us one of
the top 10 enterprise apps of 2016,
which is pretty awesome.
Now we're also the largest digital
blueprint repository in the world,
we have over 50 million sheets of
blueprints in our cloud and growing.
>> Thanks.
So I'm sitting here.
We've got 40 employees,
hoping I wish I had 150.
>> [LAUGH]
>> But a little bit about Lob,
I'm one of the founders.
My name's Harry Zhang.
Started company in 2013, and what we
do is build tools and make it easy for
developers to control the offline world.
So we actually deal with a physical
component, an industry that many of you
think may be dying, but in fact,
it is very much the opposite.
Doing letters, postcards and
other types of mails and really building
a layer of technology on top of that to
make it easy for companies to do that.
So hopefully, many of you have
received a piece of mail from Lob,
especially in this area and
the Bay Area and we service companies.
We're trying to make this switch into
selling to mid-market, and other startups,
and to selling it to the Fortune 500.
So a lot of our challenges today is
really how do we move into Enterprise and
take what used to be
a lone single tool and
translate it into a larger full
solution for larger companies.
>> Good, so hang onto the microphone
because there's just one other question I
want to ask the whole panel.
But I really like to talk about the
concept of a minimum sale-able product,
not a viable product, like what it
actually takes to make real money.
So Harry, tell me what happened with Lob,
do not count other companies from
your batch, or customers [INAUDIBLE].
How did you get those first
[INAUDIBLE] customers and
what made the product sale-able?
>> Sure, yeah, I think one of the common
things that's easy to get in the habit of
thinking that customers are going to come
to you because you have a great product,
have a great solution.
That works maybe in the beginning for
smaller companies, but
as you go after your first real customer,
our first real customer was
Oscar Insurance over in New York.
So the way we got to
them was cold email and
we sent thousands and thousands of emails.
I personally wrote every single one and
got a response from the CEO.
And I think one of the key
things is to really
have an understanding of why
are companies going to talk to you?
What is the problem you might be solving
for them as supposed to like here
is what my product does and
these are the features that I have, right?
You want to be very pinpoint
about what the message is.
People are actually surprisingly open
to respond your email as long as it's
relevant.
So for us, we happened to hit
on the problem for Oscar,
which is they had a mail vendor and
they knew there was this regulation called
HIPPA which is essentially how you govern
and control private health information.
And what we realized was that
this was our opportunity and
they're looking at new vendors.
They did not trust their existing
vendor had HIPAA and was secure.
And we could point to a small
customer we had already done it for
in the past and
that's how we got into the conversation.
Took us about two or three months to get
the deal done, but really what you need is
to identify a core problem that larger
companies haven't quite figured out and
even if your solution isn't
the best that's out there,
it needs to be to a point where
the customers are willing to buy.
So we started off with one use case.
Very, very simple explanation of benefits.
Today we send probably 50
different types of mail, checks,
postcards, practically everything, but
But the key is to pick one small use case
that they have a real problem around and
that you're going to go solve.
So that's what we did with Vosker and
he notes, and it's funny that he stayed,
he's still one of our larger customers,
and
it all just came from like a three
sentence email to their CEO.
>> Do you remember what
the headline of the email was?
>> It was like,
we can help you with your mail.
>> We can help you with your mail,
that worked?
>> It did work.
>> [LAUGH]
>> We've now learned a lot,
that's probably what I do today.
But at the time we knew that healthcare
sent a lot of mail, and we also did
that you've got mail, which got a pretty
good chuckle from folks in a day.
But really did, the core of the content
was in the first two lines which was like,
we know companies have problems
to secure audible mail,
we built a technology
solution around doing this.
Do you have 50 minutes to talk about it.
That's pretty much what
the core content was,
but the key is to get
straight to the point.
What are you going to solve?
What's the problem and asking for
a little bit more time.
I never talk to CEO but he pounded me down
the chain but that got right eventually.
>> So Tracy, I'm not an expert but
you're probably competing with
bigger traditional older incumbents
in some ways than Lob was, right?
Do I have that wrong?
What got you salable,
what got you really off the ground?
Beautiful software is great, but
we all want to build that, right?
What made it salable?
>> Sure, our first ten users,
I'm trained as a construction engineer, so
the first ten users were definitely
people we had worked with in the field.
And it's easy to get our friends
to try out our software.
It's incredibly difficult to get
our friends to start paying for it.
So-
>> That is a difference.
>> Building something that they wanted and
that they needed that
added undeniable value to their day to day
was the moment they started paying us.
>> Was the feedback from your
non paying friends useful?
Was it unhelpful?
Was it dishelpful?
>> So our first beta group which included
mostly people I'd worked with in
the field was about 30 people.
29 of them started paying us
as soon as the beta was over.
>> They did pay you.
>> Hm-mm.
>> Got it.
So were they bigger critics
than outside customers?
Sometimes it's hard to figure on how
to take advantage of friends as your
own customers.
>> Yeah,
yeah you're really testing my memory.
>> [LAUGH]
>> So no, it was at that point in 2011,
2012 is about I want this to do more for
us.
Can you build the XYZ?
>> Got it, and obviously the product
was FuturePoint at the time, right?
What was the one piece
that was 10X better?
>> So blueprints are at the core.
PlanGrid replaces physical blueprints.
Fold-out maps, we don't have them anymore.
Actually with this group,
you guys have probably never
purchased a fold-out map before.
>> [LAUGH]
>> But we use Waze, we use Apple Maps,
we use Google Maps, and
with blueprints, it's the same analogy.
These massive, incredibly dense
pieces of paper with information, and
they just don't render
quickly on PDF viewers.
So it was just-
>> So what was the one line,
what was the pitch to make your
beautiful product salable?
Was it [CROSSTALK]
>> I'm really glad.
I was hoping you would ask
me what the tag line was.
>> What was the tag line?
>> Our tag line, and
this is from my co-founder, Kenny.
Our tag line was Plangrid
eliminates the ****.
Except that marketing has now changed it.
So we're the productivity software for
contraction.
>> Got it, okay.
We'll dig more on that, so boy,
where do we want to answer this questions.
So we start hosting applications,
right for others?
>> Yeah.
>> What's their early history?
Tell us what didn't work, or at least
didn't scale and that what did work.
>> Sure.
>> So you can sell the product.
>> So the background here is, so
nine years in, we started out as
a company called dotCloud, and now
we're a different company called Docker,
but there is a common thread, right?
It's the same company, it's the same
team with the same mission but
we changed how we do it.
And the first phase of dotCloud, well, let
me start with what the common thread is,
the common thread is we help
developers be more productive.
We give them tools to create applications.
And then we help the businesses
behind those developers
solve their business problems
with the creation of software.
And we're serving on these
trends of more people
creating software to do more things.
So at the first phase,
we did that by hosting the applications.
So we said, just write the code, upload it
at to us, we'll take care of everything,
we'll run it for you,
we'll manage it for you, all of it.
And, and then now, as Docker, we don't
do the hosting, we provide the tools.
You use the tools yourself, and
then you host the application and
eventually as a business,
you need help with various aspect of
distributing your software at large scale.
So in the first phase, we're very small,
we didn't have any sort of hype behind us.
We were just trying to convince
developers to use our stuff.
Honestly we used our own community, where
programmers, we write software, and
we know a lot of other programmers and
we just annoyed the hell out of
all of them to use our stuff.
We gave it to them for free, and then kind
of through the individual programmers,
eventually made our way to
the business behind the programmer.
So the difference I think is that,
for us it's a two step process
that our users and our biggest advocates
are not the people paying for the product.
So, that means we have to
give a lot of stuff away for
free before we even get the first
conversation with the actual buyer.
>> Yeah.
>> So those first early years,
it's not even the same product
you have today remotely, right?
How did you survive?
Did you raise 50 million
in your seed round?
>> No.
>> How did you pull this off, right?
Surviving's the hard part, right?
>> Well, so
when you;'re a very small team,
you have kind of a limited window of time
where you could survive and earn a lot.
>> Yeah.
It's hard usually for that to last
more than 24 months, isn't it?
>> That's right.
But, yeah, so
we joined Y Combinator in 2010 and
raised our first small round of funding
at the end of 2010, so within six months.
And we just went at it gradually.
I mean,
it's nothing particularly unique there.
>> But you got into YC about
24 months after founding.
>> Yeah, so
the frist part was really tough,
it was bootstraps,
we did consulting, we did whatever.
>> Consulting was the hack.
>> It was the hack,
whatever we had to do to pay the bills,
it was really tough.
My advice would be consulting and
product building,
they're very useful but
you gotta get out of it
really quickly because the consulting
takes all of your time.
You will never get off
the ground as a product company.
There's too much distraction
in consulting, so
eventually we just took a leap of faith.
>> Yes.
>> And
landed on our feet in Y Combinator, so.
>> Got it, and then one last question and
then I want to move on to the next topic.
But so what is now Docker
has gone through two and
a half evolutions of business model,
right?
And you've made Open Source work for
you, right?
What's the secret there?
What's the learning?
because we think it's hard
to monetize Open Source.
>> Yeah, so
honestly I don't know how useful
my insights are here because really
the trick is to get really lucky.
[LAUGH] And
the situation we're in now that
the Open Source technology that we
developed, Docker, is extremely popular.
>> It is.
>> We were in the right
place at the right time,
there's this whole trend on containers
which we kind of help start.
And now, just the demand for
it is honestly hard to describe.
So, you
start having a completely different set of
problems once you are in that situation.
So, honestly the problems we had
before that moment in 2013 when
we launched the Open Source Docker and
after, our world's apart.
>> Yeah.
>> Now,
honestly it's more, How do we
deliver on the incredible demands
fast enough before
the competitors do it instead?
So there is no outbound in our case,
the question is too much inbound.
Which seems like nice a thing,
but it's actually-
>> It's noise.
>> It's noise and
also you drop a lot of it on the floor and
your competitors pick it up.
>> Yeah, so, Tracy,
I want to come back to your fun story.
You hit up 30 of your friends from
construction and 29 became customers.
As you scale,
what do you do with customer feedback?
How important is this?
How much do you listen to?
How much of it is noise?
How much do you let it guide your roadmap?
What have you learned?
>> I don't know how you build
product without listening to your
customers' feedback.
We certainly take it incredibly seriously,
we've logged and
categorized every single piece of feedback
that our clients have given us since 2011.
It's incredibly easy
we've made that process.
You just come on plangrid.com and
you're like, I want to give you feedback.
And then our support team will take it and
they'll ship it over to the product team.
We'll look at it every quarter and
it does help us prioritize.
The big task here is making sure that
we're prioritizing the right stuff.
Because sometimes our users will ask us,
can PlanGrid make up my breakfast and
dinner.
And so,
when there's large general contractors and
smaller subcontractors and building
owners asking us for the same button.
And telling us that if you just have this
thing, it's going to save me so much time,
and there's enough domain
experience on the team.
When so many customers are asking for
the same thing,
it's probably the right thing to build,
although tracking is obviously important.
But we typically look at it as,
how hard is this to build?
How much resources do we have
to put into this versus,
how much value and
impact is it going to give our users?
And if it's low level of effort and high
impact, we're going to prioritize that.
>> Absolutely.
>> And that's really helped
us guide our product roadmap.
>> And have you had any of
your bigger customers drag
your roadmap in a different way
than your smaller customers?
>> Yes, the larger customers, they want to
be treated like princes and princesses.
That they're running our entire business,
but they're incredible supportive of us.
It's nice that not any
single one customer has
that big of a percentage of our revenue.
And so they just want to make sure
that we're listening to them, and
that we're showing them what
the future of PlanGrid looks like,
and that we're constantly improving it.
Because they're not only
buying PlanGrid today, but
they're buying PlanGrid
six months from now.
It's a committment, right?
It's a relationship.
>> It's a long term commitment, right?
And so, how many customers
total do you have at PlanGrid?
>> Tens of thousands.
>> Tens of thousands?
>> Mm-hm.
>> But the revenue distribution,
it's probably several orders of magnitude
at your biggest customers, right?
>> Mm-hm, mm-hm.
>> When even if it's a couple percent of
revenue or maybe in the early days,
when they ask you to build something
that's kind of on your roadmap,
that's way out there,
because this is an issue we all face.
Did you build it?
The B2C guys always say no, right?
But when your big customer wants you to
build a 2019 feature, do you build it?
>> Again, if there's like,
a ton of the big customers asking us for
the same thing,
it's easy to prioritize that.
But, we have never built a feature out for
just one customer,
that doesn't make sense.
We're building software for
the construction industry,
not XYZ Construction.
>> Got it, yeah.
Harry, Lob, is there a difference
between different sized customers?
>> Definitely a big difference
between our large and small customers.
We spend a lot of time focusing
on the larger customers.
I think one thing you mentioned earlier,
right?
Do our larger customers
impact our roadmap?
They certainly do, right?
That said, I think it's also about
being transparent in the conversation,
from the first deal,
like what are you building?
You're not just selling
one particular feature,
one particular item,
it's a roadmap, right?
It's like you're investing at Lob, you're
going to be building infrastructure on it.
We need to talk to that roadmap and
when larger customers are purchasing,
they're looking at what are we
building six months from now,
trying to understand what that is.
And for us, it's about finding
the balance between the type of
customers that we want.
And listening to those customers a little
bit more that are more strategic.
So for us, we're selling something
that's very ubiquitous, right?
Mail comes in many shapes,
formats, sizes, and
there's literally endless amounts
of combinations that we can do.
And if we entertain every single request,
we'd end up going a million
directions all the time.
So for us, we focus very
strategically on operational mail.
So mail that customers are compliant and
required to send as
opposed to marketing mail.
That's not to say we don't do a lot
of marketing mail, we still do.
But when we think about
roadmap conversations and
it comes to a trade off between A or B.
We're always going to look
at the customer who one,
we have a relationship with, right?
Two is the direction that we want
the company to move to begin with, and
that's how we prioritize it.
And sometimes,
that means saying no to customers.
And oftentimes we found
they're okay with that, so
long as you're transparent
about what you're trying to do.
>> Yeah, Solomon, let's talk,
you said in the beginning you guys were
five co-founders for two years, right?
I think.
>> No, that.
>> Roughly?
I have that wrong?
>> No, I think I heard five co-founders
>> Was it Tracy five?
>> Yeah.
>> We'll get into equity splits later.
>> Okay.
>> At minute 51,
until I learn how to add, okay?
But any related questions, so
I wanted to ask most of the panel this.
As you scale, let's talk about,
because this is always a great learning,
a mishire, right?
So as you get out your core team,
is there a core functional area or VP or
someone that you thought you needed or
got wrong in the early days?
Anything you can learn from?
What's the biggest hiring
mistake you've made?
>> I don't know about the biggest but
we made a lot-
>> [LAUGH]
>> We made a lot,
I don't know anyone who hasn't.
>> Yes, but we can learn from this for
the next week, right?
>> Yeah, we can.
>> This mistake a fewer times.
>> Yeah, I mean, the biggest challenge is
once you've grown to full-fledged company,
then you grow outside
your zone of comfort.
If you're in the technical and
product side,
then you'd have to hire business
people for the business side.
You have to hire more technical and
product leadership.
And, it's things that at
some point you don't know.
And you don't know what you don't know.
And I remember as an engineer,
hiring non-engineers,
it was very difficult for me.
Because I knew I needed help but
I didn't have the know-how to
distinguish the different kinds
of non-engineers that I needed.
It seems really silly to say that,
but to me marketing and
sales, it was like the not coding thing.
And also, I moved to the US from France,
and Americans are extremely
good at selling themselves.
>> You know I hear a lot
from European founders.
I hear that as a consistent theme.
>> And so you're out here,
and you meet ten people.
Wow, these are all rock stars [CROSSTALK]
>> Hire them right then and there.
>> Yeah, and you do.
And then you realize,
okay, there's more to this.
And the biggest problem is you're
when you hire the wrong person,
the state of mind is, it's a bad person.
They're bad and my company's good and
now I hired the bad person.
But really what's happening is,
everyone's wasting their time.
It's not the right
combination of people and
you're going to find out six months later
and it's going to be a terrible nuisance.
So I don't really know if I've
learned anything how to avoid it.
But, every time we made a mistake, we've
tried to really invest the time to go
back and find out why, what we did wrong.
So that we don't make the same
mistake twice, honestly.
And I guess.
[CROSSTALK]
>> It's not the hired's fault,
it's your fault, isn't it?
>> Yeah, exactly, that's exactly right.
And my feeling is it's
the hardest at the beginning.
But if you find,
once you have a core group of people,
like five key people in areas that you
don't really Understand and master, but
you build a relationship
of trust with those people.
>> Yeah.
>> Then it gets easier because you
trust them to hire more people.
The really bad situation is if you
don't sort out that stuff early on.
Like you make a hire,
you feel like it might be a bad hire,
but you don't deal with it right away.
You allow it to Fester.
And then before you know it,
you're growing and
that person has hired 20 more people.
And now, you're in big trouble.
Because now, you gotta deal with
the mismatch, potentially, with 20 people.
So my only advice would be,
you're going to make mistakes, just deal
with them early and listen to you're gut.
If your gut says, maybe this is
the wrong thing, trust yourself,
even if it it's not your
field of expertise.
I mean, I'm probably repeating
common sense here, but-
>> We all make the same mistake.
Tracy, I want to hear your story too,
but let me flip it around.
You've five co-founders,right?
So you've got, you felt like you had
at least two of the bases covered in
the early days, at least in theory, right?
What was one of these early hires you
made that was extremely impactful,
that moved the needle,
that helped increase the business?
>> Our employee number one.
>> Employee number one, who was that?
>> Cora Lorenz.
Where early on there's nothing, and
you have to build something from nothing.
The more people that we can
get on the team to help
realize our mission as a company
is incredibly important.
And I would say the same
about employee number two and
employee number three and
employee number 300.
>> Yeah.
Was there a particular functional area or
someone that changed things for you?
They're all great.
>> [LAUGH]
>> I mean we brought them on because we
needed help, right?
So it's hard to just pinpoint one person.
>> For sure,
well let me ask you a different question.
You have five founders, when do you
bring on VP's or Directors or others to
take over the function layers, from that
what do you learn from that experience?
>> The point where we realize that as
being a founder especially doing it for
the first time, so much of our jobs
is just learning on the spot and
trying to get the job done.
As we've recruited more and more people,
the team, there comes a point where it's
like, wow, we have to become
really good at managing people.
And this is all new for the founders.
I think we got pretty good at it,
especially as just a frontline
engineering manager.
But there comes to a point
where we're at 50 people,
150 people, and it's like Dunbar's
numbers, like complete chaos.
Suddenly communication gets so
much harder.
And I think that's when we started
layering in executives who had
done it before.
Because now we have the experience of
people who aren't like the founders,
aren't learning on the job,
they've done it before,
they've done it three times
before very successfully.
And it just is much easier to
run the business that way.
>> Yeah, that's a good insight of when,
we all want to hire the folks that
have done it before early, right?
Not all of us, but we get attracted
to the box on the resume, but
maybe that Dunbar number is the right
time to think about it, right?
When did you benefit from folks that maybe
weren't as fluent in the product, but
were fluent in the processes?
>> Yeah, if I could do it over,
I'd probably bring them on earlier,
but at that point, it's just like you're
trying to recruit someone who's very,
very good at their jobs who are getting
paid tones of money where ever they're at.
And it's hard to recruit them to your,
you know, little **** start up,
but you sell your butts off,
actually you never stop selling your butts
off about your mission,
your vision as a company.
And so being able to deliver that
message of what you're trying to do and
also showing the traction,
showing the growth.
When you see that graph,
everyone wants to be a part of it.
>> They do, yeah.
Was there a moment,
recruiting was always hard, but
was there a moment when it got easier?
>> Practice.
Practicing gets easier so I'd say maybe-
>> But from a brand perspective.
Get to the point?
Did Sequoia or others, or Press or
you, I want to ask a related question,
but did it get,
in some ways easier when you became
a more interesting startup
to a broader community?
>> Yeah, so we're a YC company,
we're also in the Sequoia portfolio.
We flash that to our advantage.
>> Yeah.
[LAUGH] So good.
So Harry,
any learnings on hiring mistakes or
great hire you made,
that moved the needle for you?
>> Yeah so I can actually talk to one.
You mentioned earlier just like realizing
that, you need to hire good managers.
It was a big moment for
us in the past couple of years and
that was actually one of
the early mistakes we made,
which is one of our best IC's
thought he wanted to be a manager.
And we really wanted him
to managed a team too.
He hadn't actually had
experience doing that before and
when we put him in that role,
he struggled.
And that had some, that put us
through a tough six months, right?
And I think we learned a lesson early on,
it's like you want people who have already
done it once before because even though
you may trust somebody and they're awesome
at what they do, it's hard to discount
the value of experience, right?
And that's something,
like just having seen it before,
the type of problems you can see,
that's made a big difference.
So for us, like I said,
our first most huge hires,
like, we had somebody in our head
engineering role that didn't pan out and
our second head of engineering
was just incredible, right?
He literally made problems disappear.
Like things that we would sit there and
worry about.
I'd be there and
my co-founder talking about this and
this people issue and next thing we knew.
Literally three weeks after we started,
we just never talked about it,
heard about it again.
Everyone seemed to be happy and
working harder and staying longer.
And we didn't really feel like we
were doing anything different.
We just had somebody
different on the role.
And-
>> How quickly did you know, 30 days?
>> What's that?
>> How quickly did you know it
was impactful, an hour?
>> Probably it was, so we had
the advantage of already having someone on
the role, so we sort of knew what
good looked like and what great was.
And obviously we are always
looking at that,
but the first three days I think
the difference they are having as a team.
Even within the first two
weeks a lot of learning, and
you can just tell from the quality of
question that they're asking, right?
What are they thinking how
far they planning ahead.
And then really,
we started to see a lot of changes happens
in second week in terms of, what I taking
care I learned throughout the interview
process, get to know the company.
And also adapting it to there own style,
right.
And I think, first of for most it's like,
not just hiring for experience but
hiring for culture fit is really,
really important.
We have had great hires in the past,
awesome IC's that we let fester a little
too long, because of cultural things.
And having to rewind that back a few years
later it was definitely challenging.
So I think culture fit now,
like we spend a ton of time
through our interview process.
We've updated our values,
worked into the interview process,
each person is responsible for
asking one particular component of that.
And that's like one of the first
things we evaluate, regardless or
not whether the person can do their job,
it's like is this someone we'd work with,
and is this someone who's going
to fit well really bring their own
individual skill set to the company.
>> Yeah, it's a good point.
Tracy, let me go back to a point you made
about the journey that your customers
are signing up for 6 and 12 months,
and maybe they're even signing up for
60 months and 100 months.
Especially in the early days,
products are super feature poor, right?
I mean, you had 29 folks sign up
immediately, but it's still, how do you
convince them to go on that journey when
you have incumbents that are feature rich?
What did you learn?
>> There's nothing like
adoption in the field.
So there's certainly lots of incumbents,
some that you know very well.
There's also a lot of start ups here, and
that are just, if you have any success
at all, your software will be copied.
You guys are dealing with that right now.
And so just making sure that we
are developing products that are actually
being used in the field
has been key to success.
That regardless of what VP of operations
or CIO's want to deploy, the software
that's being used on construction site
>> Yes.
>> Like for real is our software, because
we made sure we were building software for
the superintendents and foremen, and
carpenter, and electricians in a way that
is actually powerful to them that
actually helps them Do their jobs better.
>> So this is learning from me, but
a lot of your history is coming in from
the field, even if the CIO's office or
whoever it is.
>> We build software for them,
too, so we've got admin panels.
We have SSO coming out for them.
>> Yes.
>> We've got beautiful graphs and stuff,
because they are a decision maker and
that's important to us.
But I think early days,
I mean first four years of Plangrid-
>> Yes.
>> We were definitely not prioritizing
products for the people in the office.
>> And how and
let's just talk about that for
me because that's always interesting,
right?
And so, you get in through the field,
they love your product.
They can adopt it immediately instead of
taking six months, and how did you deal
with that conflict if a different
vendor had already been selected by.
Or, any learnings on how to-
>> Yeah.
>> To deal with that [INAUDIBLE]?
>> Our industry is super interesting
because we essentially sold a construction
projects.
There certain construction companies that
manage like several projects at the time.
But the beauty of our industry, and
it's also both like the best and
the worst thing is,
when we're in a construction project,
there's actually 50 different
customers for us to sell to.
There are the carpenters,
there's electricians,
there's the concrete folks,
the pool installers, the paint person.
And so, there is this natural virally that
happens within construction projects.
The foreman starts using Plangrid,
and it's a cultural thing too.
As a construction person, you just
want to show off your shiny new tool.
And Plangrid's so
cool that you sort of want to be the first
one to show everyone else on the project.
And so, we were always laser focused at
building something that was easy to adopt,
easy to use,
and that we sort of sparked that network
effect within construction projects.
So, here's corporate standardizing on
a software, then you've got the field,
which the person paying for
it really is the building owner.
>> Yeah.
>> And so, we've just been laser focused
at getting our software adopted,
At the ground level,
which is very different than any
other software in the space.
>> And you spent a lot of time on those
other users that actually don't pay for
a Plangrid?
All the other folks in the project,
how do you make them happy too?
>> Yeah, we made sure to build something
that was flexible enough that could be
used by anyone in the architectural,
engineering, and construction industry.
Prioritizing products
is a key factor here.
>> Yeah.
>> We didn't
want to build something that was just for
one profile.
We wanted it to be flexible enough that it
could be used by everyone in the industry.
>> Yeah.
So, Solomon,
let's talk a varying of these sort of
competition, a long journey for you.
I feel like Dockers a product and
a vendor that people are rooting for.
I think there are a lot of
the Docker fans, I would say.
How do you invest in that,
how do you return that social contract in
the product side especially as
competition increases, right?
As you prove yourself, everyone wants
to do something in the broad container
the market, competition's everywhere.
How do you keep that like
100Mbps the Docker probably has?
>> Yeah, so,
>> Do you measure MBps?
>> We measure it well,
[LAUGH] we measure in Mbps.
>> Happiness?
[LAUGH]
>> Yes, we do.
The problem for us is, who do we ask,
because there's a lot
of different audiences.
Actually, it's a really
interesting comparison to,
I think the same thing is
happening in a lot of industries.
There was a sort of a bottom-up
go to market, right?
Where, first you get
the partitioners on boards, and
then, you get their bosses on board,
maybe later.
Maybe they learn about your
product only once, Dozens or
hundreds of people in
the organization are using it.
>> Even today at Docker?
>> So it's, yeah, so we use that-
>> There's a real gap in some-
>> We use that heavily, yes, yeah.
And so today, as a business,
we target enterprises,
very large businesses, that is our focus.
We sell also to small businesses,
we're kind of in a similar situation,
you've got the tens of thousands and then,
the majority of the revenue
comes from a few hundred.
But all of them are in this
relationship with us as a vendor,
because someone on their team
at some point said, new app,
awesome Docker,
I went to meetup, sounds great.
Or, I saw a discussion online about it.
So, we owe everything to that community,
and
there's a lot of positive
vibes in that community.
Honestly, it's pretty insane, if you've
ever been to a Docker meetup or DockerCon.
>> DockerCon,
that was like 5,000 people, right?
>> It's just, it's ridiculous.
>> So, in the early days,
how do you facilitate that?
What are the learnings?
How do you get that flywheel going?
>> Honestly, we started something
very small and the day, ten people,
we showed it to a few people one by one.
And then, ten of them came back to our
office saying, hey, we want to know more.
And it was just the most
fun three hours of my life.
Basically we were just talking about all
the cool stuff that we could build with
Docker and then they came back the week
after that, and it was 40 people, and
then it was 100.
So pretty, there was a first week
of the existence of Docker, right?
>> Yeah.
>> And so, right away we saw,
okay, there's something special going on
here, and there is a community forming and
they're basically saying, hey you,
the company who started this,
you're the janitor now.
Like make sure that organize things for
us, because this is our thing now.
And so, we just took that job
really seriously of enabling that
community to do whatever it decides to do.
So, we've been following
that community ever since.
And just removing obstacles for
that community to grow,
do more things together.
And so we have a whole team that's focused
on that, just enabling the community.
We have all these cool programs.
We have, I think,
120 meetups in the world.
100,000 people have-
>> 120 meetups a year, all right.
No, so it's 120 locations in the world,
each with an average of a meet-up
every two months or so.
>> Got it.
>> And then 100, 000 people I think,
overall have showed up at least
once to one of these meet-ups.
There was a captains program which
is sort of like elites power user,
where the most savvy and
articulate users of Docker.
We kind of promote them, and pay them for
them to go and speak at events,
and they just become these
stars in the community.
It's a huge investment for us, but
all of it is about giving back.
>> Got it.
How many captains
are there out of curiosity?
>> I think now, there's maybe 20, 30?
It's a small number.
>> It sounds like a lot to some of us.
[LAUGH] Yeah, it's a lot of captains.
>> It's a lot of captains, yeah.
>> But you said, you had 400 employees.
I mean, they're not employees, but
it's a significant amount of
your extended family, right?
>> Yes, correct.
Yeah, and so anyway, when you see
a community, when you see anyone super
excited about what you're doing,
just drop everything you're doing, and
make sure you put themselves
at their service.
In our case, it's the developers,
using an open source tool, but
it looks like there's
something similar going on.
I'm sure there's,
I'm going to say it wrong, but
whatever the job is of someone actually
working on a construction site,
some of them, I'm sure,
are just huge fans of the tool.
And they go everywhere, and
they just tell all their buddies about it.
And, I think that's how
consumer products used to grow.
>> Yes.
>> I think now, it's increasingly and
seeing the best B2B products
also grow that way.
>> So let's make that our last question.
I want to save a few minutes for
questions so we have it.
But related to that, I think I
already know the answer for Docker.
Lets just do Plangrid and Lob.
But, Tracy today, what percent of your new
customers come from a word of mouth or
a brand?
Or, does all these great good will
that you built across the industry,
how was that pay off today?
>> I mean we definitely ship
Facebook ads and stuff, but
most of our new customers comes from
just word of mouth organic growth.
Which is awesome, but
then it's also uncontrollable, right?
Just some, it kind of comes naturally to
us, and we don't know what sparks it.
But, we know that if we make our clients
happy and we build a great product for
them, that that does continue to happen.
Year after year.
>> Yeah, is that happening at Lob yet?
Do you get most of your
customers from the base?
>> Yeah, our base customers are the folks
that are referring a good portion of our
[CROSSTALK].
>> So you're not having to send all
the emails yourself today anymore, right?
>> No, I mean, what we've actually found,
similar to what Solomon was saying,
one of the things that's interesting,
we have these folks have been at three
different companies in a four-year span,
and have used Lob at three companies.
>> That's when you know it's working.
>> Yeah, we see this all the time.
And it's great because every time I get an
email from them, it's a different company.
Hey, I want to bring you here.
I was like great,
I love the challenge from you, right?
And you want those folks who
are going to be your evangelists,
who love your product, everywhere they go,
they going to find a way to use you,
because they like it, right?
And that's really important,
and that played a big part for
some of our regular customers going to
different companies, bringing us there.
And then you also get the referrals,
especially what you want to do is
you want to create word of mouth.
And we've found this to be very
successful at conferences, right?
Where we already have a good
foundational layer of companies.
So for us, Fintech and
the lending space is a big one, right?
So we're going out, we're at LendIt,
and our customers will
bring their friends over.
For our booth, well yeah,
these guys are great, right?
And there's nothing like a positive
referral for all from someone who is
existing customer to somebody else
that's doing something very similar.
And that is part of the reason
why we go every single year.
And we sit there, we smile, we host,
customer appreciative of that.
And eventually we'd love to get to
the point where we can do like a Lob Con,
get a bunch of folks together.
>> You may be ready already, actually.
I think, right?
You may be ready.
All right.
We'll keep going on this, but
let's take some questions.
Anyone got any great questions for
the panel?
>> I was thinking what was one past
experience that you think helped
you the most while
starting your own company?
>> Jason, can you repeat the question?
>> I can.
>> The question was what was one- You're,
sure right.
I like redundancy.
I worry.
I like five nines of uptime.
What was one experience prior to starting
your company that actually helped
you get it off the ground?
>> So two of the five co-founders of
Plangrid had built buildings before, and
the other three were building software.
Just our ability to rally resources and
people, and build something together,
the ability to work together really
helped us work in a startup together.
It just feels like
the medium's changed for me.
Instead of concrete and brick,
it's people in code and more people.
>> Do you think you can penetrate
the industry with no domain expertise?
I mean, I am sure it's been done, but
what's your learning on domain expertise?
>> I think it's possible.
You just have to become an expert fast,
so somehow you have to compensate for it.
>> I can comment on that one a little bit.
I didn't have any domain
expertise in mail,
I don't think a ton of people
had domain expertise in mail.
>> [LAUGH]
>> I am an expert now, though, and
certainly that's something I've learned.
But for me past experience, right?
I came out of college I went to Microsoft.
And this is like the last place in
the world you'll expect to send mail and
have it be effective.
One of the projects I worked on there, we
follow multiple different privacy reasons,
like we're not allowed to email.
We couldn't do it through the channel for
another couple of reasons, and my only
option was either calling everybody which
didn't seem very feasible at the time, or
sending people these nice little kits.
And it turns out like the best performing
thing was mail, and I ended up
spending three months in hundreds of
thousands of dollars, it's a huge budget.
So working on this, and realizing that
this is something like people actually do,
and companies like Microsoft
do everyday and it works.
But it's really hard and it's ancient.
We had people suggesting us,
like automation, paying tens of thousand
dollars for implementation to get an FTP
folder that we drop an Excel file into.
And it seems sort of ridiculous but
I was part of the inspiration for
how we started working in Lob.
>> Go ahead.
>> What are your thoughts about big
companies who can offer a competing
service or product that can damage
their operations expertise like Amazon?
>> Yeah, or let's how do you deal with
big companies that can do it all, right?
How do you deal with that situation?
>> Sure, yes.
>> [LAUGH]
>> I think there's probably,
there's a generic answer that's true for
every business, and then there's for
every startup, and then there is
maybe some domain specific answers.
I think, personally I think
something that's true for
all startups is that you have focus and
you have speed.
And I had never worked at
a large company before, so
I did not appreciate exactly the advantage
we have as a smaller company.
But now that we're growing a little bit,
I can already tell what
happens when you grow.
>> [LAUGH]
>> And so
the goal really is to take advantage
of our small size while we're small,
faster than we accumulate
problems as we grow.
When you're big and you have a successful
business, everyone working there,
the majority of people working there.
First of all we're not there at the time
when the business became successful, so
they all, it's long forgotten how they
became successful in the first place.
They're administrating
an existing cash cow.
And so there's a completely kind of
people, generally speaking, right?
Except maybe the very top.
You got a few VPs there,
the original guy who did it and
then he's running something.
But usually these
are people who at a large,
your average large company,
they're not united as one group
to make that company succeed
against outside threats like you.
They are focused usually on their career,
are they going to get promoted?
Are they going to get
more people under them?
It's inside facing rather
than outside facing.
And most large companies are like that.
And that's an advantage,
because they're not looking for threats.
The other advantage is focus.
Large companies tend to
be doing a lot of things.
And when you're competing with a company
that has 10,000 people and you have ten,
it might seem really daunting.
But the particular parts of that company
that is actually competing with you, for
all you know might also be ten people.
And they might be underfunded, they might
be on the wrong side of the big boss who
just doesn't care about their product.
And over time, as you start competing,
you'll find out which ones are serious
threats and
which ones are basically to be ignored.
>> It's hard to tell from the outside.
>> Hard to tell but as you start becoming
an expert, and you talk to customers,
I mean it's pretty easy.
Customers are going to say well I'm
thinking about you and these other two,
three things.
And some names are going to come up a lot,
and some of them will be other startups,
some of them will be other big companies,
and then you narrow down your focus.
And you figure out okay, what makes that
big company smarter than the others?
But you can break down the problem,
basically.
>> Go ahead.
>> What do you think the biggest factors
that lead customers to tell other
customers about your product?
>> That's the magic question,
what do you think the biggest factors
are that create this word of mouth?
They get other customers to refer you out.
What can you point to specifically?
>> I mean the short answer is good
product, something that saves them time.
At the end of the day
that's all we care about,
we've got this one precious
thing that we don't get more of.
And because PlanGrid absolutely
saves our users time,
it's why they've told everyone else.
>> But
let me just buried in that question.
So you had the great story of
the customer that left, the three X,
that's a great story.
But in B2B it's hard for
that to happen in three weeks, right?
How long did that take to get that,
there's three customers out of
that first grade experience?
>> Yeah, I think the first thing I
realized is customers aren't going to just
all of a sudden start
referring them to you.
They want to build a relationship and
trust you.
And the only reason why that happened is
because the first year It went from this
particular individual,
like start off as a very, very small,
like couple of $1,000 a month customer and
grew to be like 50,
$60,000 a month customer, very,
very large in a short period of time.
And we did a lot, like in a lot of things,
we are very transparent,
like hey, we can't get this done in
this time frame, here's what we can do.
I had a cellphone number we
frequently text when things go wrong.
And for us, I think the biggest
reason why he actually went and
referred us is because of how we handled
things when things didn't go the way we
planned, right?
Everybody wants projects to go perfectly,
launch on time.
And the reality is it doesn't
always happen that way.
And sometimes there's factors out of your
control, but I think the way that we
handle ourselves when things didn't go
planned was a huge vote in confidence.
That this is a company that we can trust
because we were watching people scramble.
And I remember there is once instance,
around Christmas some deliveries
didn't happen for key customers.
We went out and drove out, and
just delivered it, because I was yeah,
the guy's down the street is not a big
deal, we'll just go and get it done.
And he was hugely appreciative.
I know it was a small thing, right?
And it was a very small
campaign that he was doing.
But stories like that that he clings on
to, when he goes to a new company, and so
the reason I worked with these guys is
because they did all this for us, right?
And when things were not going well, they
still stepped up and did the right thing.
And that's why they love us today.
But I think it starts with
having your product, right?
>> Mm-hm.
>> If your product's not good,
no matter what you do for the customer,
he's probably not going to take you.
Because then he is
putting his job at risk.
>> Yeah.
>> You should wrap up right there.
>> Wrap up right there?
All right, let's thank the panel.
This was great.
Thank you everybody.
>> [APPLAUSE]